life is slowly returning to normal in
under outside of durban three days after
torrential rain and flooding caused
widespread damage this is the first day
clonipani pakamani has been able to
operate his food business which he
relies on for a daily income
the floods have really affected us the
people who used to support us could not
come and buy because they were not even
going to work
even the little money they had they had
to use elsewhere
with the water and electricity supplies
still cut off clonipani does not have
anywhere to keep his stock city
officials are yet to begin clearing and
rebuilding some of the roads and bridges
which collapsed were destroyed by
mudslides
at a home tola kelem swami's cleaning up
she says as the flood level reached as
high as the rooftop her five children
just managed to make it out
safely lost everything my kids birth
certificates school books and clothes my
fridge my television nothing's working
as you can see around here and i've not
received any help i only managed to get
blankets from my neighbor
resident notando
says some food has been distributed but
people in this ward have not received
any and they have to make use of
whatever they can to get by
most of my community members are using
the stream where the water we don't even
know where it's coming from so to wash
our laundry and also drink from this
contaminated water
while people try to recover it could be
short-lived more rain is expected in the
coming days
many people living in informal
settlements like this one already
struggle to make ends meet the
destruction caused by the flooding has
set them back even further and many say
they've not received help from the
government that's despite its promises
to assist those affected familia miller
al jazeera durban south africa